صباحنا اليوم نسائي بامتياز حيث يجتمع
العالم لقول صباح الخير لكل نساء العالم
بمناسبه يوم المراه العالمي الذي يصادف
الثامن من شهر مارس لكل عام المراه التي
ما زالت تبحث عن المساواه تبدو امام واقع
صعب يؤكد فيه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو كوتيرج اسفا ان المساواه الحقيقيه
بين الرجل والمراه هدف بعيد المنال ويحتاج
نحو 300 عام على اقل تقدير لتحقيقه ورغم
ذلك فان الامم المتحده تبحث عن الجديد
الذي يقرب المراه من المساواه وهذا العام
يبدو الابتكار والتكنولوجيا احد اهم الطرق
من اجل المساواه بين الجنسين والامل في ان
يكون تمكين النساء تكنولوجيا سبيلا
لمساواه اكبر حيث فتحت اعمال الدوره
السابعه 67 هي لجنه وضع المراه مركزه على
الابتكار والتغيير التكنولوجي والتعليم
الرقمي لتعزيز سد الفجوه بين الجنسين
[موسيقى]
المراه طبعا مثل المطر ما تنتظر شكر ولا
عرفان يعني المطر اذا نزل لا ينتظر لا شكر
ولا عرفان بطلت اليوم من العراق يا رينو
الجافيه اول امراه عراقيه تقود طائره
حربيه رينو انتشرت عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في نوفمبر 2022
بعد ان حصلت على اجازه قياده طائره حربيه
بعد 150 ساعه من التحليق في الجو وهي اول
امراه بالعراق تقود طائره حربيه منذ عام
1949 اذ في عام 1949 كانت اول امراه حصلت
على قياده طائره مدنيه وليست عسكريه جوزيف
حداد بعد 73 ساعه من الطيران بالحقيقه
السيدات المصريات كتير خلال الفتره اللي
فاتت فاحنا عندنا لاول مره المراه المصريه
بتجلس على منصه المحكمه بمجلس الدوله واول
مره المراه المصريه تمثل النيابه العامه
امام محكمه الجنايات وكمان لاول مره
المترو بقياده نسائيه زي ما حكيتوا انا
اخترت النهارده وحطت المترو تكون خلفيتي
في البث ده وانا دايما باسعد باقسام
النساء لمجالات كانت حكر على الرجال فكل
عام والمراه المصريه والعربيه والعالميه
تحقق احلامها بحريه دون قيود كل عام جميع
النساء بالف خير قصتي عن الحاضره الغائبه
السيده اسماء خضر التي تستحق اليوم ذكرها
في هذا يوم المراه العالمي رحلت في عام
2021 وهي ناشطه حقوقيه اضافه الى انها
سياسيه اردنيه شغلت الكثير من المناصب
منها كانت وزيره للاعلام اضافه الى انها
كانت عضو في مجلس الاعيان وكانت وزيره
للثقافه مرتين متتاليتين لكنها ايضا ناشطه
حقوقيه محاميه في معهد تضامن النسائي
الاردني نادت بحقوق المراه وما زال هذا
المعهد يعمل كانت ضد زواج الفتيات في عمر
مبكر كانت ضد اعفاء الرجل المغتصب في حاله
تزوجوا من الضحيه بان يعفى من العقاب كانت
تنادي بالتجنيس ابناء الاردنيات وكانت
تحمل كثير من السيدات من خلال دعوه ما
يعرف بجرائم الشرف جميع طبعا وبهذه
المناسبه ساتحدث لكم عن المراه الاكثر
اثاره في عالم التكنولوجيا ميرا موراتي
وميرا تبلغ من العمر 35 عاما فقط لكنها
كبيره المسؤولين التكنولوجيين في شركه
اوبن اي اي الشركه المسؤوله عن تطوير
الروبات الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي اكتسح العالم مؤخرا وكنا قد غطينا
هذا الموضوع في السابق
ميراث تخرجت عام 2012
بكالوريوس بالهندسه ومنذ ذلك الحين والى
الان وهي تقود فرق في اهم الشركات
التكنولوجيه العالميه منها شركه تسلا حيث
عملت لمده ثلاث سنوات تحديدا لتطوير طراز
من هذه السياره الكهربائيه ثم انتقلت
للعمل مع شركه ليب موشن وكان املها ان
تلغي الكيبورد من الكمبيوتر او
اللوح لوحه المفاتيح املا بان تجعل
الكمبيوتر علاقته بالناس وكانت قد تحدثت
انا قالت انها تامل ان يتعامل الناس مع
الكمبيوتر كانهم يلعبون كره القدم